[Musique]
il est le premier pape à se rendre en
irak le souverain pontife est arrivé ce
vendredi à bagdad une visite de quatre
jours à la rencontre de la communauté
chrétienne et pour poursuivre le
dialogue avec le monde musulman et les
flics en particulier le vague françois
qui a fustigé les barbaries du groupe
etat islamique ainsi que la corruption
qui mine le pays
[Musique]
les européens ferait mieux de se
préoccuper de leur propre problématique
nous revient sur les récentes sanctions
européennes dans le cadre de la sphère
navali à des sanctions encore devait il
ya quelques jours avec washington
la diplomatie russe juge que le lieu est
sous pression américaine
[Musique]
le gouvernement français n'exclut pas
d'imposer la vaccination aux soignants
malgré la priorité qui leur est accordée
depuis deux mois seuls 30 % d'entre eux
ont aujourd'hui reçu le thé romantics au
vide dans un courrier ce matin le
ministre de la santé les enjoint se
protéger pour eux et pour leurs malades
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france que se taisent
les armes les mots du pape françois peu
après son arrivée ce vendredi à bagdad
une visite historique en irak la
première d'un pape dans ce pays ravagé
par les guerres une visite sous haute
sécurité en raison de la menace
jihadiste quatre jours au cours desquels
souverain pontife ira à la rencontre de
la communauté chrétienne et des
musulmans dans un discours dans la
capitale irakienne cet après midi il a
condamné les violences
les extrémismes et l'intolérance écouter
indispensable il est indispensable
d'assurer la participation de tous les
groupes politiques sociaux et religieux
et de garantir les droits fondamentaux
de tous les citoyens que se taisent les
armes que la diffusion soit limitée ici
et partout que cessent les intérêts
partisans ses intérêts extérieurs qui se
désintéresse de la population locale
assez de violence d'extrémisme deux
factions d'intolérance
le souverain pontife doit s'entretenir
avec l'ayatollah ali sistani plus hautes
autorités pour de nombreux chiites
d'irak et du monde directeur des
opérations de sos chrétiens d'orient
françois xavier gicquel nous explique la
symbolique de cette rencontre et enfin
les flammes en forme ce que c'est une
des personnalités chip les plus
importantes et les plus influentes du
monde chiite et je pense que
politiquement c'est extrêmement
important d'avoir ce dialogue pour la
paix pour pouvoir vivre ensemble et pour
espérer un avenir en commun en irak qui
est un pays qui connaît des problèmes
très importante pour la corruption mais
aussi la difficulté de vivre ensemble
pour les différentes communautés
qu'elles soient sunnite ou des minorités
mais également de toutes les autres
composantes
ils sont au coeur de cette mosaïque et
l'irak les yazidis et kaka et les
shabaks les turkmènes et la stature du
pape qui est à la fois
un chef religieux d'une communauté
extrêmement importante mais aussi un
chef d'état qui arrivent et qui parle
d'égal à égal avec des autorités
politiques et religieuses avec les
autorités civiles
en effet c'est extrêmement important
pour l'avenir à la fois des chrétiens en
irak mais je pense de la communauté
irakienne tout entière qui a besoin de
symbole d'unité on ne pas va rencontrer
le grand ayatollah ali sistani
donc on peut espérer que les ministres
qui lui sont fidèles qui sont plutôt des
misfits nationale et nationalistes
irakienne rendent leurs armes durant
l'espace de quelques jours histoire de
garantir un peu de paix durant ce voyage
est un dialogue inter religieux qui
soient pérennes mais je pense que les
forces de sécurité irakienne et les
forces de sécurité kurdes sont vraiment
bons sur le pont pour garantir le bon
déroulement bienvenus un retour sur les
tensions diplomatiques entre moscou et
bruxelles
il ya quelques jours la russie qui a été
la cible de nouvelles sanctions
européennes et américaines dans le cadre
de la sphère navalni la diplomatie russe
estime aujourd'hui que bruxelles est
sous pression américaine
ils ont déployé un véritable arsenal en
faveur de notre opposition une offensive
est en cours je la porte parole du
ministère russe des affaires étrangères
la correspondance à moscou de vera
goffman le kremlin suit de près
l'évolution de la situation avec les
sanctions occidentales a affirmé le
porte-parole du président russe dmitri
peskov
la russie va respecter le principe de
réciprocité
un imposant les sanctions en réponse aux
restrictions américaines et européennes
mitri peskov a également déclaré que les
autorités russes étaient prêtes à faire
face à de nouvelles sanctions qui seront
sans doute imposer je vous propose
d'écouter
bien sûr nous suivons de près tous les
rapports de ce genre qui ne sont pour
l'instant que des rapports des médias
nous comprenons en même temps qu étant
donné le mécanisme mis en place à
washington les états unis vont annoncer
de nouvelles sanctions il s'agit
d'accusations gratuites et infondées
selon lesquelles la russie posséderait
des stocks d'armes chimiques sur son
territoire il n'y a pas de données
crédibles kg
il ne peut pas y en avoir car la russie
a détruit tous ses stocks
il ya longtemps et arrêter tous les
programmes de production d'armes
chimiques
en vertu de son obligation découlant de
la convention d'interdiction des armes
chimiques
[Musique]
la russie le comprend et en tient compte
elle envisage divers scénarios afin de
protéger des intérêts du pays et de ses
citoyens de la manière la plus efficace
la porte parole de la diplomatie russe
mairie zakharova a quant elle pointé du
doigt le soutien de l'opposition russe
par les pays occidentaux selon elle
l'union européenne qui ne ménage pas ses
efforts en faveur de l'opposition en
russie négligent en revanche ces
problématiques internes que ce soit le
cas des gels et jaune ou la sphère
julian assange écoutez malheureusement
de nombreux pays de l'union européenne
joue à la fermeté de principe
cela concerne de nombreuses questions
les relations avec la rue
si l'incapacité et l'impossibilité de
défendre leur principe sous pression
américaine
cela s'applique également à la
problématique des droits de l'homme
étant donné qu'ils ont déployés en
faveur de notre position hors système
un véritable arsenal une argumentation
des possibilités de soutien en termes
politiques d'information mêle de tout
vous voyez qu'une offensive est en cours
washington et bruxelles ont annoncé le 2
mars des sanctions à l'encontre de
plusieurs hauts responsables russes
en réponse à l'empoisonnement présumé et
l'emprisonnement de l'opposant russe
alexeï navalni des mesures de moscou a
souligné l'inefficacité est la
vaccination des soignants france
va-t-elle être rendu obligatoire le
gouvernement ne l'exclût pas inquiet que
seuls 30 % d'entre eux est aujourd'hui
reçu le sérum anti qu'ovide les
ministres de la santé a expliqué ce
matin que 400 mille doses d'astrazeneca
avaient été distribués aux hôpitaux pour
le personnel mais qu'elles n'avaient
toujours pas trouvé preneur elles
serviront donc au public dans une lettre
qu'il leur a adressée obligé vers en
joie les professionnels de santé à se
faire vacciner
et il pose la question de la
responsabilité je suis convaincu que le
taux de couverture va augmenter si nous
constations que malgré cela et malgré
tout le travail que font les soignants
vis-à-vis de leurs collègues eux mêmes
cela ne suffisait pas je saisirai le
comité consultatif d'éthique nationale
pour leur poser la question de savoir
s'il est éthique de refuser de se faire
vacciner quand on est soignants pouvant
nous conduire à prendre des décisions
supplémentaires
cela peut aller jusqu'à la vaccination
obligatoire
et réactions à présent de rachidi goy
président du collectif en terre bloque
ou en tout cas au collectif interlock on
demande des équipements protection afin
qu'un maximum d'équipements de
protection dans les blocs opératoires ce
n'est toujours pas le cas on est
toujours en train de se battre pour
avoir du matériel de protection
notamment des masques ffp2 pour se
protéger au maximum durant durant les
procédures on voit créer un effet
puisque certaines sociétés savantes ni
le fait de l'aérosol isation toujours et
encore alors qu'il ya de nombreuses
études aujourd'hui qui qui contextualise
cet aérosol îles à sion ne pendant tant
de parler puisque malheureusement il
faudra équiper très largement tous les
soignants et aujourd'hui voilà c'est
plutôt ça qu'on réclame on sait que le
vaccin fait partie d'un arsenal de lutte
contre la corrida on en est certain ça
c'est pas c'est pas le problème mais en
tout cas on ne peut pas on ne peut pas
avancer que que cette histoire de
vaccins il faut voir aussi la base à la
base de la protection des soignants
rappelle aussi que à une certaine époque
les soignants qui étaient contaminés par
manque de personnel devaient retourner
travailler les médecins à autoriser le
retour au travail puisque c'était très
compliqué il y avait une forte tension
dans les hôpitaux
donc si vous voulez ça pose problème
aujourd'hui mais en tout cas
par expérience dans le passé ça posait
pas problème
ils réclament la réouverture des lieux
culturels après une manifestation hier à
paris comme un peu partout en france une
cinquantaine de militants ont investi le
théâtre de l'odéon il dit ont passé la
nuit et occupent toujours le lieu ils
demandent la prolongation de l'année
blanche pour les intermittents ainsi que
des négociations sur les conditions de
réouverture
ils exigent à un rendez vous avec jean
castex les protestataires soutenus par
la france soumise
nous ce qu'on veut c'est rester ici pour
pour obtenir une partie d'eux ne revenez
pas toutes nos revendications mais
surtout on ne partira pas d'ici ce temps
qu'on n'aura pas une corps encaisse une
convocation d'un cnt c'est à dire un
conseil national des professions du
spectacle avec roselyne bachelot est
aussi en présence de jean castex
parce que bon c'est aujourd'hui que tout
ce qu'on a demandé onesta la culture ne
fonctionne pas à mon à rien ils ont pas
ils ont pas les mains ils ont les mains
liées justement pour pouvoir faire quoi
que ce soit donc il faut absolument jean
castex soit là moi je m'oppose
radicalement la façon au gouvernement
aujourd'hui on voit considère la culture
pour lui le quoi qu'il en coûte
la culture ne mérite pas monsieur apte à
l'autre jour a expliqué que c'était un
exutoire
lors de sa conférence de presse d'après
gouvernement d'exutoire définition du
larousse dont il faut se débarrasser ce
qui gêne
bah voila je pense que c'était un lapsus
malheureusement qui indique bien que
pour ceux qui nous gouvernent
aujourd'hui la culture vos peu de choses
mais j'espère qu'ils vont un moment de
nous ouvrir les yeux la cré sanitaires
et ses conséquences économiques
illustration en espagne où le taux de
chômage a explosé
pour la première fois en cinq ans le
pays compte plus de quatre millions de
demandeurs d'emploi lester singh l'a été
au combat à barcelone comme dans toutes
les villes d'espagne
les commerces ont de plus en plus
nombreux à baisser définitivement le
rideau entre la baisse du tourisme les
restrictions en vigueur et la chute de
la consommation
la fréquentation des établissements a
baissé en moyenne de 40 % comme ailleurs
les activités de service sont les
principales victimes de la crise
sanitaire
bilan un taux de chômage qui culmine à
16,1 pour cent de la population active
contre 13,7 pour cent l'an passé un
record au sein de l'union européenne
à moi ça
le secteur est à l'arrêt nous n'avons
pas du tout travaillé depuis l'année
dernière
au début on pensait pouvoir au travail
et l'été dernier où à la fin de l'été
mais ça n'a pas été le cas
rona est arrivée la deuxième vague puis
la troisième on espère qu'il n'y en aura
pas d'autre voilà où on en est
complètement à l'arrêt et sans
perspectives réelles de date de reprise
avec plus de 4 millions de demandeurs
d'emploi auxquels il faut ajouter les
900 mille salariés actuellement en
chômage partiel
l'espagne fait face à sa plus grave
crise économique depuis 2012
si le gouvernement a déboursé plus de 40
milliards d'euros pour soutenir
l'économie
depuis le début de la pandémie les aides
publiques demeurent insuffisantes et mal
utilisé selon de nombreux analystes
économiques
il n'y a pas d' aides directes aux
entreprises comme cela a été le cas en
allemagne ou en france pour les
indemniser des pertes qu'elles ont eues
et pour sauver d'intérêt général il ya
beaucoup d'entreprises comme des
restaurants des hôtels qui ont fermé au
bénéfice de toute la population
elle aurait dû être aidé directement pas
seulement leur offrant des facilités de
crédit parce que le crédit augmentent
l'endettement et quand les restrictions
seront terminés il faudra rembourser ce
crédit
donc c'est une barrière supplémentaire
qui peut devenir un frein à la reprise
preuve de ses difficultés actuelles
l'espagne a vu son pib s'effondrer de 11
% en 2020 autre mauvaise nouvelle le
fonds monétaire international a revu ses
prévisions de croissance à la baisse
madrid compte désormais sur la
vaccination et le passeport sanitaires
pour tenter d'enrayer l'épidémie et
relancer une économie bien mal en point
direction maintenant à l'arménie sous le
décret du premier ministre pour limoger
le chef de l'armée est automatiquement
entrée en vigueur ce matin malgré
l'opposition du président arménien le
chef de l'état major avait appelé à la
démission du chef du gouvernement nikol
pashinian qu'il a vécue comme une
tentative de coup d'état militaire s'en
sont suivies ces derniers jours des
manifestations de ses partisans et de
l'opposition
nikol pashinian contesté depuis la
défaite militaire dans le haut-karabagh
face à l'azerbaïdjan
ses détracteurs demande son départ ainsi
de la mère de ce soldat mort au combat
qu'a rencontré notre envoyé spécial à
erevan
david khalifa normes arrache quartier
populaire d revan c'est ici que susan a
44 ans vit avec sept membres de sa
famille dans cette modeste maison où
d'entrée la couleur est annoncée avec ce
portrait ensanglanté du premier ministre
arménien nikol pashinian sur cette photo
harutyun manic charriant le frère de
susanna il avait 32 ans
militaires tombés au combat dans le
conflit du haut karabagh comme plusieurs
milliers d'autres arméniens suis anna
pleure sa mort depuis maintenant six
mois
un seul responsable selon elle nikol
pashinian et sa politique d'un mélo
rénale
quand nous sommes arrivés sur l'avenue
baghramian devant le parlement nous
avons décidé de rester là bas et de ne
plus bouger
je vais maintenant parler au nom du
peuple et non en tant que membre du
parti les gens exigent des actions plus
concrètes
par exemple envahir un bâtiment tels que
l'assemblée nationale où le palais du
gouvernement pour balayer le pouvoir
mais le mouvement pour sauver la patrie
qui se donne pour mission d'éviter toute
violence on ne veut pas de violence
on veut juste renvoyé ces autorités
entière méniennes le plus calmement
possible
ils ne sont pas
car il est clair pour le monde entier
que seule la turquie et l'azerbaïdjan
les soutiens mère de deux enfants
elles s'inquiètent de leur avenir pour
changer des choses
susanna se rend tous les matins dans ce
bureau l'une des nombreuses antennes du
parti de gary tsarukian principal leader
de l'opposition arménienne
il incarne pour susanna l'espoir d'une
nouvelle armée ni derrière son
ordinateur
chaque jour elle appelle tous les
partisans antipas chignon à se réunir
devant le parlement pour réclamer son
départ
yes nous avons étudié l'histoire et nous
savons que le haut-karabakh a été
transféré en azerbaïdjan et c'était nos
termes historiques en 1994 lorsque nous
les avons libérés les bonnes terres
assez d'effusions a déclaré que six ans
que territoire devrait être je blâme les
veines ter petrossian robert kocharian
serge sarksian est le principal coupable
et nikol pashinian s'il voulait rendre
cette thèse il aurait pu le faire
diplomatique
pendant trois ans il aurait pu
simplement expliquer au peuple que nous
n'avons pas une puissante armée et que
nous ne pourrons pas lutter contre la
turquie et l'azerbaïdjan spa salle
comble capte cette bataille elle l'avait
quotidiennement et n'a pas peur d'y
emmener ses enfants son objectif
s'inscrit dans la durée comme la plupart
des manifestants anti pashinian
considéré par ces derniers comme un
traître depuis la défaite militaire dans
le haut-karabagh un revers vécu comme
une humiliation nationale par ces
arméniens
la proposition de législatives
anticipées proposé par nikol pashinian
est loin d'avoir calmé l'opposition qui
souhaite un gouvernement de transition
jusqu'aux prochaines élections prévues
en 2022
même si les rassemblements contre le
premier ministre arménien se multiplient
nikol pashinian peut tout de même
compter sur un important soutien
populaire
en témoignent les milliers de personnes
présentes dans la rue en début de
semaine à l'appel du chef du
gouvernement
grave
on se réveille négative atteste après
les guerres je pense que tous les pays
ont tout de suite compris ce qui est
normal mais on essaie de résoudre les
problèmes qui se fait avant et après la
guerre
notre situation sera sous contrôle avec
le temps on se se nourrit nikol
pashinian aux gens la main parce que
nous savons qui est honnête et dire ça
le président de son côté dans l'impasse
également après avoir refusé à deux
reprises la révocation du chef d'état
major de l'armée
la constitution arménienne l'obliger à
accepter cette motion malgré la pression
de l'opposition parlementaire
le décret entrant en vigueur ce vendredi
au nic gaspariau sera dans l'obligation
de quitter ses fonctions de commandant
militaire suprême des forces armées
quoi qu'il en soit cette situation
aggrave une crise politique qui ne
trouve pour le moment aucune issue est
le chef de l'onu se dit très préoccupé
par la violence
au sénégal il appelle à la désescalade
la justice sénégalaise a décidé de
maintenir à l'opposant haussmann son
cours entre les mains des gendarmes il a
été remis en garde à vue ce vendredi
après sa présentation à un juge
de nouvelles émeutes ont éclaté dans la
journée des scènes de guérilla urbaine à
dakar opposant les forces de l'ordre des
centaines de jeunes
pressenti comme l'un des favoris pour la
présidentielle de 2000 24 ousman sonko a
été arrêté mercredi officiellement pour
trouble à l'ordre public alors qu'il se
rendait en cortège au tribunal où il
était convoqué pour répondre à des
accusations de viol une arrestation qui
a entraîné dans la foulée des
manifestations un peu partout dans le
pays qui au moins un protestataire a été
tué hier sous tension l'état a décidé de
suspendre le signal de plusieurs
télévisions privées je vous propose
d'écouter l'avocat de semaine sans qu
que personne ne se trompe
l'arrestation des demandes sont que
relèvent d'un complot d'état
l'empêchement pour qu'ils aillent
répondre à la convocation
l'élève encore de manoeuvre son
arrestation et sa conduite à la section
de recherches avaient uniquement pour
but de faire en sorte qu'on puisse les
déférer et au niveau de la cave que les
juges puissent accéder à l'eau pour le
placer sous mandat de dépôt alors du
point de vue de la procédure ils ont eu
des difficultés
ce sont ces difficultés qui ont fait
qu'ils ont agi de sortir également le
monde entier le monde entier a assisté à
un scénario désolant un état qui se dit
démocratique d'un état qui accuse il
était respecté un chercheur associé à
l'ipc au groupe afrique
amadou bâ revient et sur la situation
sénégal à ce mouvement on peut dire que
c'est une manifestation qui peut
perdurer comme aussi c'est une
manifestation qui pour pas si c'est une
affaire de moeurs une affaire privée qui
a viré à une manifestation générale et
d'expression d'un mouvement social de
contestation au niveau de la jeunesse ce
qui est aujourd'hui confronté à une
situation dramatique mais ce qu'on peut
dire aussi
nous sommes dans une situation
préélectorale il ya deux cas qui sont en
train de se positionner le camp du
pouvoir avec le président macky sall qui
a carrément un bon villa et qui peut
aujourd'hui faire pleuvoir son bilan on
peut dire aussi de notre classement son
coût est devenu un souci pour la
jeunesse sénégalaise est accompagné par
les étudiants mais une jeunesse ne peut
pas dire aussi faire n'importe quoi il
faut être responsable et poser les les
doléances
elle parlait parce que coco et une de 5
ha aujourd'hui intérêt à ce que le pib
donc nous devons préserver les acquis
démocratiques car le sénégal a été
toujours une victime de démocratie
avant de deux ans de la coupe du monde
de football au qatar des voix s'élèvent
contre le traitement réservé aux
travailleurs étrangers sur place dans
des conditions particulièrement
difficiles et avec une protection
sociale quasiment inexistantes il
s'affaire depuis près de dix ans à faire
sortir de terre les infrastructures
nécessaires à l'organisation de
l'événement un rythme effréné qui a
provoqué plusieurs milliers de décès les
détails avec thomas bonnin un petit pays
de moins de 3 millions d'habitants va
accueillir le plus grand événement
footballistique du monde en décembre
rien que cette phrase suffit à faire
grincer des dents
de nombreux observateurs et passionnée
de football mais au delà des critiques
sur le choix du pays organisateur c'est
aussi la manière dont les choses se
déroulent sur place qui fait débat il ya
quelques jours le quotidien britannique
the guardian révélait ainsi avoir
dénombré grâce à divers sources
gouvernementales pas moins de 6500
travailleurs migrants ayant perdu la vie
depuis l'attribution de la coupe du
monde au qatar
des ouvriers indiens un népalais ou
encore sri lankais qui sont morts
notamment en raison des conditions
dramatiques dans lesquelles ils
travaillent sur les chantiers de
construction des infrastructures de
l'événement un bilan terrible et très
probablement sous-estimé temps les
remontées d'informations sont
compliquées
les recherches du guardian ont également
mis en évidence le manque de
transparence de rigueur et de détails
dans l'enregistrement des décès au qatar
les ambassades à doha et les
gouvernements des pays d'origine des
travailleurs hésitent à partager les
données
peut-être pour des raisons politiques un
rythme de travail effréné dans des
conditions climatiques suffocante
car si les footballeurs auront la chance
de jouer leurs matches en hiver et dans
des stades climatisés
ce n'est évidemment pas le cas des
milliers d'ouvriers venus en grande
partie d'asie du sud
du côté du comité d'organisation de la
coupe du monde au qatar on affirme je
cite regretter profondément toutes ces
tragédies
tout en contestant les allégations sur
le nombre de travailleurs décédés
d'après le qatar seuls 37 migrants
auraient perdu la vie alors si des
progrès ont été obtenus grâce notamment
à la pression des ong présentes sur
place les conditions de vie
et de travail reste à la limite de
l'acceptable amnesty international a
publié de nombreux rapports sur ces
questions pointant entre autres
l'exploitation de milliers de
travailleurs nous révélons que des
travailleurs migrants sur un chantier de
stades de la coupe du monde de football
2022 au qatar
on travaille jusqu'à sept mois sans
salaire ce cas est la dernière
illustration accablantes de la facilité
avec laquelle il est encore possible
d'exploiter les travailleurs au qatar
face à toutes ces informations
l'autorité suprême du football la
puissante fifa est également pointée du
doigt
il faut dire qu'elle n'a jamais vraiment
haussé le ton face à des agissements
connu depuis plusieurs années il ya donc
ces chantiers de la honte mais aussi les
accusations de corruption pour
l'attribution de la compétition et enfin
ses récentes images qui ont choqué lors
d'un match organisé par la fifa à doha
la capitale qatarie deux arbitres
féminines n'avait pas pu serrer la main
d'un prince qatari présent pour la
remise des médailles des faits qui
s'accumulent et qui ne font que
renforcer la défiance envers cette
première coupe du monde organisée au
moyen-orient pour autant malgré tout
cela les délégations occidentales
restent étrangement silencieuse
indifférence ou cynisme il a toujours
été délicat d'appeler au boycott dans le
domaine sportif
ça n'avait pas empêché le royaume uni de
le faire en 2018 avant le mondial mais
cette fois là il se dérouler en russie
et on termine ce journal avec notre
rubrique rt sur le web sélection
d'articles à retrouver sur notre site
rt france pont tv elle est journaliste
de france 3 france 3 franche comté
dénonce les pressions de la préfecture
de haute saône pour imposer et bruno
leurs mères dans leur journal télévisé
mi février le ministre de l'économie se
déplacer à arques les grèves code médias
s'empressent alors de couvrir sa visite
la préfecture aurait donc menacé de
mettre un terme aux tournages dans
magazine si une équipe n'était pas
dépêcher les syndicats évoquent des
méthodes dignes des années 60
le procès de clément f c'est ouvert
aujourd'hui ce gilet jaune frappé au sol
par un policier en janvier 2020 et dont
l'interpellation avait secoué l'opinion
et la classe politique
étudiant de 20 ans comparaît pour vieux